the new economic numbers are in and uh
it's apocalyptic but you knew that
because you felt it yourself when you
went to the gas station and it cost you
like 100 bucks to fill up your gas tank
but yeah
the inflation numbers are in it's funny
because this story is coming out on a
friday they are terrified they're
absolutely terrified of people seeing
this 8.6 percent the highest in 40 years
and many other specific elements of the
consumer market are actually the much
they are higher than even uh
they're higher okay hold on let me try
this again inflation is higher than it's
been in 40 years but some things are
actually well beyond that going to like
world war ii the prices have never been
this high the increases have never been
the size so it is
brutally bad
and cnbc ran a survey of top chief
financial officers who said there is
going to be a recession at the beginning
of next year and it's going to get
really really bad there's nothing we can
do to stop it the funny thing is like
they're telling us that we're still in a
growth period but i don't think anybody
believes it because inflation is growing
faster than anything else
there was this chart posted by someone
on twitter it's really interesting it
shows trump's years and it's like
everything's pretty good and then right
after biden gets elected it's just wages
collapse and inflation skyrockets
so uh yeah i'm pretty sure that's it the
other thing we're going to talk about
they've got this thing called the what
was this have you guys heard about this
january 6th what's the thing that
happened i don't know you know
yeah for some reason they're doing some
kind of hearing on on january 6th it's
weird anyway we're going to we're going
to be talking about may 29th now you
guys know the insurrection on may 29th
when far-left extremists tried burning
down the white house and forced the
president into a bunker so we're going
to have uh our hearing good and release
our findings
may 29th joining us
to talk about all this we have mr andy
now
hi tim thanks for having me on again oh
thanks for coming who are you for those
who don't know
i am a independent journalist and i'm
also an a editor-at-large for the
post-millennial
right and author of the
new york times bestseller unmasked
inside antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy well then it's the you're the
perfect person here
for us to discuss the may 29th
insurrection right so thank you indeed
we also have libby she's back i'm here
who are you olivia hi i'm libby evans i
am the
editor-in-chief at the post-millennial
i'm glad to be here glad to be back
glad to hang out with andy
all you all you fine fellows well all
right then
hey guys um i i decided to fill up my
tank today i i
drive a diesel dodge ram truck
that i that i call big balls becky and
the
truck it was like a quarter full i spent
148 dollars and 32 cents i will never
financially recover from this unless you
go to luke uncensored.com and sign up on
my members area where you get exclusive
master classes exclusive merchandise a
forum and uh videos almost every single
day including an on-the-ground report
from one of our reporters josh friedman
from ukraine check that out
lukencensor.com thanks for having me hey
buddy ian crossland here i am your best
friend and your worst nightmare get
ready for this i was on pop culture
crisis earlier today it was awesome with
brett and mary and uh that's youtube.com
of course you search pop culture crisis
and you're gonna find it it was hot
pop culture christ always a great time
i'm over there on wednesdays as well i
also filled up today i sent him a
picture of the price of gas and he was
like holy cow and i was like it's insane
dude and i wasn't even buying diesel i
was just filling up my own passenger car
so it sucks it's hard to miss i'm
interested how the democrats are going
to pull this one off oh they're doomed i
had to fill up today yeah i i pulled my
tesla into the garage and plugged it in
yeah
i don't i don't know what you guys are
talking about this gas stuff i mean i
just drive an electric car so i don't
care
yeah you sound like the ceo of general
motors who recently was showing off an
electric car that they had and she was
asked by a reporter where the
electricity comes from to charge the
electric vehicle and so she pointed out
the battery and the reporter said well
but where do you charge the car and she
said well we charge it in the building
and he said well but where does the
energy come from that charges the
building and she said well you know i
think it's actually natural gas
wow no no no no no let's we'll say
we'll talk about this before we get
started head over to natural gas
we'll get into it we'll get into it
head over to timcast.com become a member
and help support our work as a member
you'll get access to exclusive segments
on the tim cast irl podcast monday
through thursday at 11 p.m we didn't
have one on wednesday because you know
we had to evacuate the building and that
sucks but uh we could use your help and
there was one up the other night so uh
also you're supporting our journalists
who we're hiring more of and you're
helping support the infrastructure we
are building a website and building
tools that are outside of big tech
silicon valley garbage and censorship so
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends here it is ladies and
gentlemen from cnbc
the recession will hit in the first half
of 2023 and the dow is headed lower cnbc
cfo survey so they asked 22 cfos
c-suite-level dudes from like i think
their fortune 500 companies and they all
basically said oh we're doomed and they
blamed the fed that was one of the
interesting things that they said the
federal reserve is a huge risk factor
for us so uh it's going to get bad
we also have
inflation
by inflation says the post-millennial
inflation hits 41 year high as gas and
food prices soar that's right you know
it i don't need to tell it to you gas
prices have hit a five dollar national
average after rapid rise
so here's what what we're uh seeing
august food shortages
gas prices are going to be through the
roof i think they're saying it's going
to be six to seven dollars nationwide so
california will be over 10 bucks that's
for sure and diesel shortages is one of
the things that i'm seeing across the
board when that happens everything else
is going to go up it's going to get way
worse and then here's the best part the
fall harvest is going to be depleted
because we had no fertilizer in the
springtime because of the war with
russia and ukraine so we're going to be
screwed i'll just say all of that stuff
in and of itself right
it's falling apart the world is and then
you see the political stuff with january
6 and i'm just like this country's
falling apart politically everything's
just crumbling how are you guys doing
we attacked as a culture we attacked our
the foundations of our country we
attacked our cultural foundations we
completely
destroyed what we were built upon
ideologically and now we are suffering
the price of that we're suffering the
fallout from that well it didn't take a
genius to see what was going to happen
ever since the beginning of covid you
could see the government intervening in
the private market shutting it down
allowing their friends to be open and
destroying any kind of possibility for
upward economic mobility it has been
destroyed people's futures have been
destroyed and these are the consequences
we are paying for these lockdowns for
these politicians that thought that they
could control every aspect of your
existence because you let them control
it well so let's start with this gas
real quick because we were getting into
this a little bit
uh
i was driving my tesla today oh and um i
was so confused why everybody looked so
angry at the gas station and i just
shook my head and it's like
silly people just get an electric car
it's only 60 grand did you wave did you
wave at them as you were driving by them
i honked and i yelled at him good and i
said you
you need to buy electric cars and the
guy will be like i can't afford electric
cars like that's an excuse you can
afford a hundred bucks for a gallon of
gas you can afford electric cars
yeah six thousand dollars
it's gonna be you
know that's what it'll cost to fill up
your car well actually check this out i
really think that's what they want so
fracking for instance used to be
it was not profitable because the cost
of fracking was higher than the amount
of energy you'd get out from it once
fuel started reaching a certain level
all of a sudden it was like okay now
fracking makes sense this is what's
gonna happen
if you're already spending a hundred
bucks to fill up your your car's gas
tank you're gonna be like well what's
300 bucks for you know a loan on an
electric car
might as well just do that i guess it's
gonna be cheaper the problem ultimately
you can't get electric cars because
everybody's trying to get it all at once
in the supply chain disruption and
there's not enough batteries there's not
enough raw materials there's there's not
enough supply to meet the demand and uh
again
the new york post just released an
article detailing a lot of the price
rises they're talking about how
restaurants went up nine percent uh when
it comes to prices groceries 11.9
percent electricity 12 percent new cars
and trucks 12.6 percent these are the
official numbers the the real life
numbers are probably a lot higher ground
beef 13.6 percent chicken 17.4
airfare 37.8
gas 48
fuel 107 percent i'll i'll tell you
where i'm really feeling those gas
prices man so you know when we were we
were trying to book a private plan a
private jet to austin it was it was 24
000 round trips
no caviar prices
excuse me excuse me excuse me okay i i
didn't finish okay
at 24 was fine
but now it's been six months 55 000 for
a round-trip flight oh well 55 is just
too much i mean 25 000. and that's that
just crosses the line
how are you doing hold on but i'm dead
serious i was talking alex jones about
it and i was like how are these people
like i hear all these stories like amber
heard just flowing on a private plane
and he was just telling me he's like
well you know look this was back in
november he's like he's like usually
it's around like twenty five thousand
dollars or find a private plane like
austin or something and i was like wow
that really is expensive that's insane i
was like we'll fly commercial it's a
couple hundred bucks and then we were
looking at flights again because we have
there's like apps that track it 55 000
so it doubled that's that's that's the
fuel shortage in the fuel increases
yeah that's crazy the other thing too is
that we are being pushed into this
electric vehicle economy
because supposedly it's more sustainable
but there have not been any discussions
about how the battery the materials in
the batteries are mined how those things
are disposed of it's not actually
necessarily more sustainable once you
take all of those things into
consideration
just like with the plastic bag thing in
new york where they took away all the
plastic bags and then they started
replacing them with paper and cloth
that's not actually more sustainable it
costs more to transmit those things you
know to transport those things costs
more to make them all of this stuff and
this is you know this is what they want
they want to destroy us and as many
times as biden keeps every time he says
that they want to remake the economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
it's just a complete and total lie they
want to remake the economy from the top
down by forcing us all to conform to
whatever bizarre ideas that they have
that aren't actually doing the thing
they think it is doing so let me let me
ask you guys your uh
libby are you you're okay with saying
what you're based out of right yeah i
live in new york how how what's it been
like i mean have the price increase has
been noticeable no not particularly
there have been noticeable price
increases in new york but not as much as
other places because we were already
paying a premium for everything
so
but i will say
i will say
um
so they haven't been recently more
noticeable they were very noticeable six
months ago so it had been like i'd pay
45 for a bag of normal groceries and
then a week later it was like you know
50 and it just kept going up now we've
sort of leveled off but i also buy way
different stuff than i used to like um i
used to make
my son really likes like the support
katsu style pork chops that i make um
i used to make them once a week and now
i make them more like once a month i'll
buy like one
meat thing
and we'll have that once a week and
that's pretty much it so
that is different there have been a lot
of different like i've been changing how
i buy things and the gas is ridiculous
what about you andy
well my i i'm just thinking about how
how hard the working class must be
taking us i think for people who are
uh have the benefit of working in
relatively secure
type of works like journalism or such
where you have that security you're
above a certain income and you don't
necessarily
feel these percentage increases or if
you do you see it it doesn't impact you
as much as those who are
living
um paycheck to paycheck
and i i didn't i wasn't aware of these
numbers until you pulled them um into
you you mentioned it here and it's so
shocking because it's like
i don't know how
a working family with children can
survive
with those type of cost increases
and it's a it's an issue that's
affecting all of the world i mean the
if you turn into the the uk press
the uh
increases in the
energy costs especially
um
the people are feeling it really there
in france they haven't recently had
their presidential elections and that
was the the the cost of living was like
they keep voting for one issue
yeah but that's they deserve nothing but
contempt no i mean it like they rioted
after you know uh they they attacks on
petrol
uh was put in and this is this is under
mccrory the yellow vest stuff yeah and
they protest they riot for 18 months and
then they're like we have to vote for
him again it's like okay
you get what you get what you vote for
dude i'm not gonna i'm not gonna no
empathy there you keep they voted for
him again
they did but i mean they
they were giving them the there are only
two options it's kind of like i don't
know
can you really blame
half of america now for suffering
because of the current administration we
have oh no i mean like the people who
voted for le pen i'm like man that sucks
you know the people who look the
majority of people who voted for these
people i'm just like
what do you want me to say about it but
if one can complain what you vote for
man but if i'm gonna play devil's
advocate a little bit i'm wondering how
would you all respond then let's say to
the argument that
look all over the world uh countries and
societies are experiencing increa
increases across the board because of
the result of the pandemic and you
cannot blame this on the current head of
state yeah so i was looking at a chart
that shows the economy in wages wage
growth and inflation under donald trump
during the pandemic and then under joe
biden and for some reason a month after
joe biden becomes inaugurated wages
collapse
and start receding and inflation
skyrockets and then i hear from people
they're like well that's because what
we're seeing now is the result of what
donald trump did and i'm like so hold on
so you're saying
that nine months of policy
so the policy from nine months prior to
the inauguration
that trump did and the and the governors
resulted in a massive spike in inflation
and wages collapsing nine months later
is that that's what they're saying
they're saying what trump did during the
pandemic resulted in this slide okay
well joe biden's had a year and a half
and it's only gotten worse so that means
joe biden's cleared those nine months he
should have done something when he got
in to reverse what trump was doing wrong
no the reality is under trump even in
the pandemic there was some it was
relatively stagnant growth was there
around two to three percent things got
really bad when governor shut everything
down but inflation was not this high
even with the spending now under joe
biden
nine months later where where is the
change where where is the recovery it's
not there they're lying they're making
it up so inflation so just really
quickly andy i would also answer you
specifically by talking about the us
dollar being the world reserve currency
it's the petro dollar so what happens
here absolutely matters and affects the
entire world especially when you have
when you have the u.s federal reserve
controlling the supply of the dollars
and when it's bailing out some of the
richest most powerful institutions in
this country it screws everyone else
over because it puts so much of that
money out there in the world market that
it devalues the purchasing power of the
dollar for the people who hold it
because it's literally being printed out
of thin air and if you look at the
purchasing power of the dollar it
continues to go down dramatically not
just within the last year two years
three years we're talking about decades
of the dollar being deliberately
destroyed and to me all of this is done
on purpose as a part of the great reset
where they're going to be building back
better after destroying the old system
and i think what we're seeing right now
is being done deliberately and it's
dangerous and it's affecting us but more
importantly it's going to be affecting
the world even more it is being done
deliberately and it's being done
deliberately in order to change society
and remake it into something that the
democrats believe will be better and
what they don't understand is that they
haven't come up with anything better
sustainable energy
renewables they're not better they're
not ready they cannot bear the brunt of
our industrial
american nation
neither can evs neither can any of this
stuff and instead of
dealing with
inflation instead of dealing with
economic issues they have been reversing
um you know trying to make changes in
society like the first day joe biden was
in office he basically eliminated
women you know from like civil rights
and has proceeded to do that so their
biggest concerns are
enforcing an ideology that very few
people but the elites agree with if they
even agree with it a lot at all if
they're not just putting it on and
changing the economy to you know benefit
themselves and their friends and their
their ideology that's all it is it's a
trash way of of running this country
maybe i'm not youthful i don't think
it's intentional i think it's just
incompetence you think it's just i think
i used to think it was incompetence
that's the thing i used to think it was
incompetence and now now i think they
are intentionally trying to destroy the
country because they hate our founding
and they hate what we came from they
hate our culture and they hate america
that's not what i think i definitely
hear you on that point but i don't think
you need to go that far it is
intentional because they said it was joe
biden specifically said he wanted to uh
take climate change seriously the
democrats said they want to take climate
change seriously greta tune burke said
how dare you and so joe biden gets
elected and he says let's shut down oil
and gas leases let's let's shut down
keystone which caused rampant
speculation and then you see this major
fluctuation in wages inflation all of
these things
it's not all joe biden's fault but if
someone comes in and says i'm going to
save the environment and then all of a
sudden gas spikes through the roof and
then they enacted policies to make it
harder i'm like well yeah that is them
doing it they said they were going to do
it they said that's why they're going to
do it so i would say
i'm not saying they want the economy to
be on fire
but
i'll say this we know they don't want
you driving cars they've said that we
know they don't want you flying in
planes they've said that we know they
don't like farting cows they literally
did say that so when they enact policies
that make it harder for you to drive i'm
like well they said they wanted this if
the end result is the economy is bad
i can't definitively prove that's what
they wanted but if people can't drive
the economy will get bad so it is the
result of what they've been trying to do
why why do you think what drives
americans to the streets in protest is
not economic crisis but things cultural
issues such as over guns abortion black
lives matter or protesting the right
well all of those things uh you have to
be really stupid to want to protest
right so guns for instance i saw uh meme
you know i love the memes on facebook
and it said
to sell a taco in texas you've gotta get
a permit you've gotta pay a fee
only use certain ingredients import them
and have them regulated well it's like a
huge list it's like how to buy an
assault rifle bring your id walk in fill
out a form have as many guns as you want
and i'm just like okay to buy an assault
rifle you have to have to do a
background check from the atf the fbi
you got a fingerprinted by a sheriff's
department whole process can take right
now they're estimating about six months
but it could be taking a year
considering they're they're a little
backed up these are called nfa items so
the people that are going out going no
assault rifles like they have no idea
what they're talking about the people
that are going out and protesting
abortion have no idea what they're
talking about we have someone on this
show a progressive and he could not tell
us what he really thought about abortion
because he just kept saying it's the
woman's choice the woman's choice and he
didn't know any of these news stories he
didn't know about kathy tran in virginia
wanting abortion at nine months and
things like that and then what was the
other one other thing you mentioned oh
the right well yeah when you watch
nothing but cnn and they're like
insurrection and you hear aoc going he
pounded on my door and went where is he
you are completely brainwashed in a cult
so of course you're angry and frustrated
because they keep just beating you over
the head with this craziness meanwhile
you have people who are associated with
the quote unquote right which includes
post liberals moderates libertarians
conservatives who are like i actually
read the news about guns and oh i
understand it's a nuanced issue it's
hard to solve i actually read the news
on the abortion stuff yeah those people
are crazy aren't they then you actually
see antifa and here's what i won't get i
don't understand why the right
isn't marching in protest against all of
the waves of destruction caused by
antifa the 529 insurrection when when
leftists set fire and tried to raise st
john's church when they set fire to a
white house guard post when they tried
to actually break down the fencing of
the white house and the president was
forced into a bunker and the right what
are they doing they're going january 6
is dumb and i'm like they're sitting
here screaming january 6 in your face
and you're saying nothing but yeah well
you're dumb you'd think the right would
be like
may 29th may 29th over and over and over
again and say let's play that game the
right never does all they do is respond
to whatever this left is doing that's
because the right for so long has been
completely overtaken with this idea of
the live and let live culture like okay
you want to do whatever your thing is do
it in your own house you know you don't
have to talk about it we don't have to
deal with it publicly that's all fine
we'll let it we'll let those crazy
people do whatever they want um and so
they there's no real conservative
culture of an intentional protesting
type of pushback we're not seeing that i
think we're starting to see that a
little bit more i think we're starting
to see that bubble up and you know i've
only just become aware of organizations
that are intentionally trying to do
stuff like that
but it's new i mean conservatives need
to create a culture of demanding their
rights and of demanding justice it it
hasn't
it hasn't existed up until this point it
just hasn't existed yeah i think that
people have you ever had that problem
where you eat a bunch of sugar and then
like you have no energy after that
you're just exhausted for like a day or
two days or something i think people are
living in that state right now and
they're just
a lot of people are unmotivated to get
up and to scream it's starvation will
make people crazy that's something like
we talk about the left are motivated to
organize and mobilize over and over and
over
yeah including over non-issues i think
maybe uh and hoaxes
when people are on psychoactives like
adderall and stuff that
their emotions are very flippant and
they can be pushed with like uh
spectacle really easily so a burning
building or a guy getting punched can
make people like become enraged and go
do whatever the news anchor tells them
to do especially when they're on
psychoactives
um i think that's what part of where the
population is coming from the crazy
thing is we know that a lot of these
assassinations throughout history have
been just really deranged people i mean
what was it hinckley just got released
right now you've got the 9-1-1 call
being released about the guy who went to
assassinate kavanaugh and he he's on the
phone saying i need help i need
psychiatric help something's wrong like
the dude was just
was nuts and so these people turn on the
tv and what do they see they say chuck
schumer going like you will pay the
price and he's like yes yes then he sees
the address posted by ruth sent us and
he's like yes yes then he buys a plane
ticket gets the weapons shows up and
then fortunately this guy turned himself
in that's why i don't like like um
elizabeth warren would use this flowery
rhetoric we need to fight to get our
something then fight and fight but to
the people on psychoactives what they're
hearing is i need to fight and they
really think they got to go fight
somebody and then they they
i mean they're out literally out of
their mind yo did you guys
i heard uh uh no good the quartering got
swatted again is that is that uh and
rocato believe so yeah yeah
on twitter i think he was streaming with
rakeda and i think he got swatted while
he was doing that but both of them
at the same time that's what i heard
they both got swatted at the same time i
think so see i'm telling you man
everything's just imploding like yeah so
here's here's what i was saying the
other day
if the federal government will not
enforce the law these people should up
to kavanaugh's house they won't do it
then someone actually tries to kill the
guy
and they still won't enforce the law
against these protesters that is them
outright saying we do not protect you we
will not protect you and in all in all
reality genseki encouraged them to do it
yep they're outright saying we are the
ones against you like the protesters in
the federal law enforcement effectively
the same thing as far as i'm concerned
then
you have the will the unwillingness to
actually enforce the law or i mean
they're probably happy it's happening i
can only imagine you have the swattings
against us now the quartering raketa and
other people
and they say we can't stop it
so if you can't do anything to protect
us and you won't enforce the law to
those that seek to do us harm
how is there a country at all this is an
awkward tyranny yes we were talking
about this yesterday that that's exactly
what it is it's law-abiding citizens
being held to account and everyone else
gets to do as they please and if you
notice also the
the powers that be they protect the
leftist protesters but they come after
the conservative ones i i'll never
forget in lansing michigan i'm pretty
sure it was lansing early on in the
pandemic i think it was in april you had
a bunch of people whose businesses had
been shut down not the casino casino
owners they were fine not the liquor
store owners they were fine but gretchen
whitmer had shut down all of these
businesses
nail shops and hair shops and like
whatever else so all of these people
went to lansing they protested at the
state house there they were called white
supremacists they were dragged out of
there you know all of these things when
conservatives protest for their rights
to just exist they're the ones who are
vilified they're the ones who are taken
out just like the you know the j6 people
how many people did they take down in
that and it's all being tried with
misdemeanors how long have they spent in
jail no trial you know and last week you
had joe biden saying that none of our
rights
none of our rights are absolute and you
can see that his doj means it because
these people don't get a speedy trial
right we have a right to a speedy trial
we have a right to reasonable bail these
people aren't getting that joe biden
means it when he says that our rights
are not absolute he's 100 on that that's
why i say
we've probably been in civil war for a
you know for a while now
people just don't recognize it because
they expect warfare to stay the same and
i blame fallout the fallout franchise
naturally because ron perlman keeps
telling us that war never changes but
war actually changes quite a bit
um that's why there's multiple
generations of there's different
generations of warfare and strategies so
now we're dealing with is we have this
report whistleblowers claiming the fbi
has been purging conservative agents
okay is that right that's we that that
that was it's reported that several
whistleblowers came out and said people
who are conservative are being called
disloyal and they're being removed
you take a look at the gop front runner
in michigan getting arrested and charged
on several misdemeanors but the fbi
raids his house that's right and then
they dragged him out of there they drag
him out so anyway you cut it the federal
government is now arresting opponents of
the democrat of the democrats and it is
a democrat administration basically
criminally prosecuting and targeting its
rivals meanwhile you have people
terrorists who are who are showing up to
the homes of justices
with no accountability
someone literally came out to kill
kavanaugh and merrick garland still will
do nothing because
i mean let's be real they're into it
merrick garland and the protesters are
the same facts they want it to happen
janseki said we encourage this yeah
and then the dude shows up
lori lightfoot called people to arms
that's right literally over over what
was happening with roe v wade in this
league and this guy wasn't it like may
9th or something yeah she said it's a
call to arms and we must fight for our
rights and we will not allow it and then
this guy
he heard it apparently and then he shows
up
fortunately he turned himself in we're
very very fortunate the guy had a moment
of clarity to be like okay this is this
is crazy
but this is what happens when they
incite they encourage and then they
don't hold they don't enforce the law
i would say
the the federal government's
unwillingness to enforce the law here is
they are involved themselves in
stochastic terrorism do you know what's
interesting though too what is
stochastic terrorism it's when you say
things like we certainly encourage
people to show up and protest in front
of these people's houses and then
someone shows up with weapons to kill
the person who lives there so it's kind
of like oh won't someone rid me of this
priest and then someone goes and kills
the prince i never said to do i was
speaking rhetorically charles manson
apparently that's how he uh was like
sure be great if some people showed up
at their house and wreaked havoc or
whatever he told and then tex and the
rest of them went to the house and
killed a bunch of people manson was like
i never told him to do it yeah you kind
of insinuated that maybe they should
so when genseki encourages them to do it
laurie lightfoot says call to arms
literally and then the guy
shows up
and then merrick garland okay this one
guy is getting charged
right that's their line actually trying
to pull it off
but the people who are protesting in
front of the homes they're they're
committing a federal crime
and the federal government's like no no
that's that's fine we want
hyper partisan pressure applied to the
courts we that
that's the reason why you can't do this
is that there can be no justice unless
the courts can function that's why we
have the rule the law in the first place
this is actually the legal justification
if you can't have courts be free from
political pressures then you can't
actually have justice no then there's no
justice at all which is why we said no
protesting to sway a court's opinion
judge james brought this up the other
day judges are not elected officials
right they're appointed i mean some
judges are actually but these these
federal judges are appointed so you're
not going to change if they're if
they're going to be in office or not
what you're trying to do is force them
to give the ruling in your favor which
is not justice
and that and the and merit garland the
federal government biden's
administration the doj they are they are
in favor of all of this but if you look
at even what happened in virginia right
so we had protests outside john roberts
house chief justice
um and
there was a recent election in virginia
everyone thought it was really going to
shake things up glenn younkin
conservative came in um to lead virginia
and he didn't do anything about the
protesters outside robert's house he
posted on twitter that he was monitoring
the situation and it's like yep no like
as you know as my friend jackpot said it
was like no the rest of us are watching
what's going on you're supposed to
actually do something you're the leader
of this state it is a federal law i'm
not sure there's a state law prohibiting
them from doing it so they don't have
the jurisdiction oh is that right that's
my understanding i could be wrong though
yeah the idea is that merrick garland
would be the one who have to say this is
a federal law that you are breaking and
have to go in you'd think after someone
showed up to kill the guy he'd be like
okay okay okay okay we're going to get
people out of here right now
so
i i'm just telling you
january 6 hearings nothing on may 29th
it was a total it's a total show trial
it's preposterous and that they brought
in a daytime tv guy to like do the
production on it prime time they i
thought it was a good morning america
guy oh it's abc a former president of
abc news is it yeah he probably did good
morning america yeah i think he did but
it's just so ridiculous it's so obvious
and transparent what they're doing
they're propagandizing this entire thing
just to try and make it so that trump
can't run again and so that all
conservatives are vilified as white
supremacists well the reality is
conservatives don't care that a bunch of
leftists tried burning down the white
house and forced the president into a
bunker i mean you can argue no of course
they care yeah but they don't care
nearly as much as the left does the left
doesn't want to talk about how they
actually set fire to st john's church
and a white house white house guard post
and tried ripping down the barricades
they did rip down the back they did but
i mean like the actual they wanted to
actually breach the white house
150 officers were injured in that
and conservatives don't bring it up the
right i mean i i hate saying
conservatives but
every single person in opposition to the
violence
yeah we can sit here and be like yeah
antifa gone too far but we're not
funding hearings there's no conservative
right-wing libertarian moderate
millionaires or billionaires being like
we need to get all these politicians to
do prime time hearings about what
happened on may 29th when the president
was forced in the bunker by a bunch of
far-left extremists it never happens
that's just one example of what the
right is never willing to do meanwhile
the left won't shut up a right-wing dude
can fart in an elevator and you know
next to a senator and they're screaming
people in pink hats
storm the supreme court they go to the
supreme court they're banging on the
doors and they're screaming they show up
to the senate buildings and they're on
every floor screaming and they shut it
down that's not an insurrection they go
to the white house and set fire to a
church nearly burning it down it's
called the president's church
they set fire to the guard post as i
mentioned they tore on the barricades
and tried breaching the fence 150
officers harmed the left doesn't care
and apparently the right doesn't either
so long as regular people are caught
between a news cycle showing constant
images of violent maga people and the
right just keep saying no no no well
then the only thing regular people are
going to see is the right wing being
violent what do you think they should do
uh i think people on the right should
have been having hearings on may 29
endlessly i think the first thing they
should do in uh once they're all sworn
into congress on january third is
they're gonna they should impeach joe
biden and they should have hearings on
ukraine and barisma and the and the
private equity deals in china and they
should hold hearings on 529 and they
should say 5 29 5 29 over and over and
over again and never shut up about it
and then this is brilliant and then
here's what happens you know what i do
i'm sitting in i'm sitting in the
congressional hearing and they say we'd
like to have a conversation with you
about this uh big tech social media
policy and i would say thank you for the
question on may 29th far left extremists
set fire to a church outside the white
house and they've reached the barricades
injuring 150 police officers and they
force that sir sir we're talking about
big time oh i'm sorry
yes so as i was saying on 5 29
that's what they're doing yeah that is
what they're doing and i've got i i you
know they're posting memes they are
going nuts now i will say it's the
economy stupid they can try and do
everything they want i don't think it's
going to save them
but it's certainly when it comes to the
political violence and the escalation of
culture war the right never
never stands up and says
this is the subject the news cycle is
always being set by the establishment
well we're always just reacting we're
always just reacting to what they're
doing 5 29.
what was interesting too
they talked about that whole wasn't that
the wasn't that when they kept insisting
that trump had gone over to the
president's church specifically for a
photo op
and they were complaining that
protesters had been unlawfully cleared
from that park that was the big story
from 529 and when trump was forced into
the emergency bunker they mocked him for
it that's right they laughed they said
it was funny
the republicans
so so the senate republicans are mostly
just establishment shills who are like
better keep my head down and not get
involved that we can take power back
and um you know there's relatively few
actual good politicians period right but
i think
for one
it's gonna be really interesting next
year because republicans aren't gonna
they're not gonna have a veto proof
majority and they're not they they can
they can nuke the filibuster
but
joe biden can still veto mm-hmm i think
they should just scream 529
529 the insurrection yeah the
insurrection on 529 luke you you expect
the republicans to do something and no i
don't and they don't do nothing right um
and what better way to kind of low
people into this kind of uh server to it
this kind of larger enslavement than
having
these these people up there who talk a
good game but don't really
do anything and and again when you look
at a lot of the things that that's been
happening you know a lot of people like
to blame only the democrats know the
republicans also are hand in hand
working together not serving the
interests of the general public not
helping the people out there not going
out of their way to actually serve their
representatives they serve the special
interest and if they gain power which
they most likely will you could expect
the same shenanigans that are going to
screw you over but instead of being
screwed over by the left side you're
going to be screwed over on the right
side so i don't have any hope this is
just my own political kind of ideology
from what i've seen within the past 15
years because it's it's kind of
sickening seeing this kind of left right
divide and conquer game and nothing get
achieved nothing yet done and none of
these parties actually truly address the
issues that are affecting the general
public they always talk about emotional
hyperbolic issues they always change the
conversation and we never get to the
core issue of why we are being screwed
over every single day well i think one
thing that happened with the republicans
too is they spent a long time just
worrying about you know fiscal year
afghanistan you know fiscal tax issues
things like that you know they thought
that they were above all of this other
stuff a lot of conservatives that i knew
um you know growing up or over the last
several years uh prior to this current
cultural moment were very insistent that
they were fiscally conservative and
socially liberal and i think that was a
big mistake you know i think giving up
the culture and saying whatever crazy
stuff you want to do the culture is fine
you want to destroy the foundations of
american principles that's fine you want
to say that all the founding fathers
were racist that's fine you want to tear
down confederate statues that's fine
right you want to say that the
declaration of independence was just
racist that's fine we're just gonna deal
with tax law that was a really huge and
stupid mistake because it gave
everything away it said the thing that
we're fighting for
is meaningless anyway so what's the
point of doing it you know what is it
that we are going out there and dealing
with i was at a um conference recently
tpusa this young women's leadership
summit um and i was on a panel talking
about some stuff and it was really
fascinating the most fascinating part
were the questions so you had all of
these thousands of women there young
women who um
who are really
really insistent that it's time to take
back the culture time to go for it time
and they're angry and they're really
pissed off one young woman asked a
question saying um
that she you know she grew up with you
know conservative values but so many
people around her grew up with extremely
liberal values and one of the things
about that she said was that no one knew
what a soul was
no one knew
what it meant to have a soul an
everlasting soul an internal
soul
people thought that when they had issues
that she thought might be spiritual
issues and that we potentially growing
up you know people of my age group would
think were spiritual issues or things of
that nature people thought that they
were depression that they needed to take
drugs to fix it
that they needed to be medicalized that
they needed psychiatric care to fix
these kinds of issues issues like
despair issues like depression these are
not just all issues that are in your
brain and so we have given away
religion we have given away culture we
have given away
meaning
and we are expecting anybody to be able
to stand up on anything there's no
foundation we burned it down we let them
burn it down and so and we handed them
the match andy do you have any hope in
these lizard people calling themselves
politicians
uh
no i know they're not lizard people or
i'm being facetious obviously
but do you have any hope in the current
political system where do you see things
uh from your perspective
i i spend a lot of time outside the
united states now when i go back and
or i pay attention things that are
happening here it
it actually makes me really sad like i
i don't think it's a sign of a vibrant
democracy for people to show up outside
the homes of judges to try to intimidate
them
uh impression them and harass them into
ruling a certain way that's actually uh
i think a
very uh emblematic of decay in liberal
democracy
and um all the issues we're talking
about here it's just um
it's hard to be optimistic um
it's hard to come up with like solutions
it's almost at this point it's kind of
like it's
a certain line has already been passed
where
uh
any any solutions are
maybe just band-aids i don't know maybe
i'm being too pessimistic there um
responding to libby i think
the
yes the right
the political right had
ceded culture to the left and the left
went full speed ahead and you just look
at
every
every institution
that affects culture
and it's self-replicating they have
power over and it's significant so
you know i think even if the republicans
now were to take up
um may 2020
insurrection against uh the white house
it wouldn't have really any currency to
go far because there's no media buy-in
on that narrative and
i'm i'm such a critic of the media
apparatus for the fact that they can
create certain narratives and the whole
uphold narratives are untrue and mislead
the public and misinform them
and so it's
uh
yeah if you don't have the support of
that media infrastructure you can
you can rally around a claim it won't go
anywhere
yeah but i don't i don't if you look at
the big cable networks their viewership
is substantially less than fox news and
you know msnbc cnn and hln they get less
than what fox gets combined yes but that
that and
in combination with print publications
the they are able to make the talking
points to get to the desk of those in
congress right and my point before was
republicans will be sitting down with
democrats
and democrats will say a b and c and
republicans go a b and c a b and c when
the republicans instead should be going
one two three
when the democrats say one six the
republicans should only talk about may
29th
so right now with the january 6 hearings
republicans should be having their own
hearings and any attempt at any
conversation on the house floor on
c-span or otherwise should be on may
29th then the media won't have an option
so i mentioned it's similar to with
donald trump
he was on twitter he should have gotten
parlor if he did it would have forced
the media to cover parlor and it would
have forced journalists to have signed
up for parlor to get access to his
tweets because the journalists said
outright
my job requires me to have notifications
turned on for trump's tweets that's
right but trump wouldn't do it not until
after he's he's out of the news cycle
for the most part he's still here but
he's not the president what needs to
happen is
republicans need to stop playing the
game the democrats are requiring are
demanding they play and the democrats
can come and say i've got a health care
bill and the republicans republicans
should respond with uh thank you for
bringing it up yes on may may 29th there
was an insurrection and then they're
gonna be like we're having a debate
a debate on what oh healthcare right
right the healthcare for people on may
29th the president was forced just do
not give them a chance you get a phone
call from a new york times journalist
and they say i'd like to get your
comments on this gun control bill ah yes
yes on may 29th there was an
insurrection
and then they can print no comments or
they can choose to highlight the issue
so republicans have power where they
want to acknowledge it or not and until
they decide to set the news cycle the
news cycle will be whatever democrats
want it to be
i think the public are owed a public
inquiry about not just may 29 2020 but
the
months are riots from coast to coast i
tried my best to illuminate just really
one city in my book portland there was
dozens of other city that experienced
recurring political violence and to to
this day there's really been no
congressional interest in finding out
who was before who was behind some of
these funding sources that were
channeling money to uh these pop-up
groups that were on gofundme and on cash
up in venmo
who
uh are
part of these networks that are helping
transport people from portland to
um louisville to
other parts of the united states
um
and the issue is the republicans
actually don't want to challenge it
the the democrats and the democratic and
republican party are the unit party
there was an insurgency in 2016 bernie
lost trump won
trump trump candidates ended up winning
and they didn't know how to stop him
because trump was leading a lot of the
party and too many republican voters
were unwilling to support someone like
mitt romney so now they're confused and
they're scared but i tell you this
lindsey graham and mitch mcconnell kevin
mccarthy they would love
to be having a debate with democrats
over you know how much money to print or
you know on what day do we bomb children
is it the first or the second of the
month
instead you get trump who's like abraham
accords pulling our troops out of the
middle east pulling our trips out of
syria and showing up our borders and
they don't like that they canceled the
trans-pacific partnership too oh yeah
that pissed off republicans and
democrats
part of the trans-pacific partnership
this deal where they wanted to get the
united states hooked on basically
malaysian oil was called the investor
state dispute settlement it would have
gave these malaysian oil companies the
ability to sue the united states for
discrimination if we chose not to buy
their oil and then the american taxpayer
would have had to pay these corporations
for
for discrimination and bernie sanders
was against it trump came in and like on
his third day in office basically shut
the thing down well it was like nafta on
steroids but the counter argument to
that is that there are rumors that this
deal was already dead and it didn't take
much not to go through with it because
the negotiations have failed i don't i
don't believe that they redid the deal
they did it with the all the other
countries reignited their own version of
the deal without the u.s it hasn't
stopped them before especially with
nafta under bill clinton which again
pushes globalization pushes
multinational corporate interests to
have the way with the people um and
that's essentially what they've been
doing for a very long time so what klaus
schwab wanted right yeah
corporations wants present tense yeah
that's what he wants i mean uh
it's getting i would say
wants and is succeeding at uh yeah we
were a lot of people were forced and
manipulated to take a product that they
didn't want but if they wanted to
continue and live their lives normally
they had to and you know life hasn't
come back to normal and i i ever will i
disagree with that
they didn't have to
it's only because they were too scared
that everybody ended up being having to
do something if you know if they come
out let me give this example um you
shouldn't speed
speeding is dangerous
why does everybody speed it's fun
everybody no i mean five miles over it's
still more fun than going it is it is
illegal to go
even one mile an hour over the limit
but it's like a it's like a it's like a
slap on the wrist right you get like a
minor ticket yet you go on the highway
everyone's breaking the law and for some
reason they're not pulling everyone over
the reality is it's because they can't
right they only pull over a couple of
people the people who are egregious and
in red cars if everyone breaks the law
together
then we control what the law is it's
like we were talking about pedestrians
earlier the cops want everyone to go the
same speed let me let me give it to you
a better way it's not about breaking the
law it's about the law not being
culturally relevant because we've
mentioned this before there are books
that are called like wacky laws
and i remember reading one where it's
like in massachusetts it's illegal to
put your apple pie on your windowsill
but like that's ridiculous if you did
that no one's no cop is going to walk up
and be like
and the reason for it was that back when
massachusetts was you know tiny
you'd attract animals or something right
right there's bills where it's like you
can't take showers on tuesday or
thursday and you can't water your lawn
on monday wednesday or friday those are
california laws well those are now but
like on the east coast and it was
because the local water sources were
limited so they were like you can't do
these things but now these are not
culturally relevant and would never be
enforced right speed limits are weird
because they're kind of top down
authoritarian and that like it'll say
every piece of this road is 65 miles an
hour even when you're turning and
dipping and turning when like well this
should be 45 sometimes you see signs at
night it should be slower at night if
it's raining it should be slower but the
signs always say the same number so you
have to make a judgment call that is
changing that's good there are digital
speed limit signs now they change oh
that's interesting yeah and they can get
hacked watch out don't fall for the
propaganda when it says 108.99 yeah
they're trying to get you you know i
feel like it's like that says minimum
yeah i'm going too fast this propaganda
of the left and the right and the
republican the democrat feels like a
cult party game and i'm looking at this
thomas jefferson quote i've been staring
at it that
uh banking institutions are more
dangerous to our liberties than standing
armies and if you look at the last three
or four years i think this has played
out exactly where has the us military
been in this in the midst of this
problem they're not involved they're not
messing with us the national guard's not
giving us problems it's lo it's
corporations that are manipulating
people with media it's blackrock things
like these giant conglomerate reserve
which gives them these loans they use
then buy up the property from poor
people
it's it really is and i think you know
if we want to revolt against anything
it's against the corporations it's
against the bank you know i think that
you're onto something with revolting
against the corporations because they
also unleash all of this wicked and
ridiculous messaging all over us that
doesn't make any sense that isn't even
in line with what they're doing
you know
it's that classic thing the pride month
all of the big companies are like we're
rainbow super rainbow friendly we're
covered in glitter in the u.s australia
and england and canada and then you look
at their their messaging in north africa
and the middle east and china and
there's there's no rainbow glitter you
know it's just the basic plain logo they
don't care about these things they don't
care about the values that they claim to
claim to here's the issue they just want
to push them on us and make us think
that they believe in these things and
make us believe in them too corporations
ruining the country corporations are
authoritarian yes so that is correct
with the constitutional republic you
know you have various systems of
of electing representative or forms of
governance but we have guaranteed rights
corporations have a boss the boss says
yes or no you want money i can give it
to you i can take it away
so when claus schwab is talking about
the world being governed by corporations
the the
the morsel idea they try to plan to
people is oh we're talking about people
who do the work
having say over how the work gets done
and what's really happening is massively
powerful interests who can decide
whether you get access to resources or
not
they're massively authoritarian they're
becoming more powerful than governments
themselves
he wants the authoritarians to take over
yeah and we should be careful to say
corporations exactly because i have a
corporation you have a corporation we
all have our different businesses these
are these are people who other
corporations can't even compete with
because they're on such another level
they have bribed so many politicians
they have bought them off they have the
blackmail on so many politicians that
essentially they have created a new kind
of entity that is even more powerful
than the government with how much uh
money and power that they're able to
influence our everyday lives over this
is an important distinction they're not
corporations anymore when something
becomes a mega corp whatever you want to
call it it's not it's not like a
corporation like we intended for it to
be it's not a person it's it's a it's a
group of them for instance and it's
bigger than a government i'm i can
repeat everything we just said but they
need it it needs a different word we
can't take these things seriously i'm
just imagining like
you know back in the day with medieval
warfare you had
groups of of similar people
france and britain right there they're
from the same area to the land now
like warfare very much is major
corporations but just imagine thinking
like mcdonald's private army and things
like that you know it's like our chief
export is cheeseburgers and they have a
bunch of armed guards but it's like who
owns mcdonald's no no probably blackrock
but youth
you think i'm kidding take a look at the
um the banana republic right
when armed guards went in and wanted to
make sure the bananas could be shipped
out because the bananas were the key you
know product for the company what was it
uh what was the company that
chiquita right and they like overthrew
the country yep it's like the government
the corporation was more powerful than
the government look at the stories and
they had banana guards they had banana
police look what happened with panama
noriega the stories of the economic
hitman these are stories that are
absolutely mind-blowing to show you how
these multinational corporations use uh
intelligence agencies to do their
bidding for them i mean we reached such
a crazy level where again our government
is uh for purchase and it's been bought
by some really awful people who only
want to benefit themselves and they
don't care about anybody but they don't
care about you they buy it by buying the
corporations that work within the
government like i'm just looking at
mcdonald's corp the top three investment
holders are vanguard group state street
and blackrock they own about 19 of
mcdonald court you nailed it it was
blackrock the other thing too these
corporations think that because they are
so big because they have amassed so much
money and and economic power that is up
to them to influence government policy
we saw this in florida with disney
coming after
um the laws in that state believing that
they had some sort of right to tell ron
desantis and the legislature and all of
the people of florida that they couldn't
have this parental rights and education
belt even though it was wildly popular
and corporations came out just recently
a whole bunch of them all got together
and sent a letter saying hey we demand
action on gun control it's important
that we say something we have to take a
stand and say something shut up
like shut up you go make money we
already give you a ton of money we buy
your stupid stuff we eat your stupid bad
cheeseburgers
you know you don't get a say over the
government that we elected maybe each
individual does write a letter to your
congressman write a letter to your
representative what have you like you're
an individual constituent but the
corporations that believe that they have
a right to influence the federal
government to influence the state
governments
and it's such a huge um
overreach on their part yeah and you
said it earlier that you thought this
was intentional what's happening i think
so because there's nothing more that
these people would love to see than the
fall of american democratic republic
it's the biggest then they will get to
take over they will just get to do
whatever they want what's your favorite
corporation andy
uh i don't think i have one but this i
mean this conversation i gosh i haven't
put enough thought into thinking about
the power the relationship between
corporations and government and i'm i'm
embarrassed that i'm ignorant about that
i just
and
as libby was channeling out her anger
just now you know it's it's made me so
angry and frustrated it's like yeah why
why
is ben and jerry's uh and all these
other
sjw corporations and trying to affect
legislation in the uk ben and jerry's is
trying to pressure the british
government uh against its um
uh legislation about uh sending uh
uh illegal asylum seekers to rwanda
and it's
yeah but i think the case in florida of
a corporation that's headquartered in
burbank california
trying to
tell
parents what they can or cannot have um
in
in terms of information about their
children's education that's like butt
out i'm surprised that there aren't more
people pushing back you're right that
there does seem to just sort of we just
lay down and accept that we
accept this culture where
these mega corporations with their
billions and billions of dollars can
actually try to influence
our laws
and this is easily inappropriate
trillions this used to be a left-wing
position um and now we're talking about
it well that's because the corporations
uh took all of the
um
you know took all of the tax breaks and
whatever whatever else from the gop and
then just sided with the leftists anyway
i'm trying to look is it unilever that
owns ben and jerry's
is that can anyone confirm that i'm not
sure i'm not sure i think it's uh
unilever i'm not jerry's uh i'm not
trying to ben jerry's and dove are both
on by unilever so i wonder who owns
unilever no unilever is the parent
company yeah but that's oh you mean the
investors yeah who invests oh come on
almost every corporation in the world
every publicly traded corp microsoft uh
dao you you go down the list it is
embarrassing that i didn't know it's
embarrassing for me that i wasn't aware
of this until two years ago
well i think it's probably just good
that you're aware of it now yeah
um
let's uh
let's talk about corporations oh yeah
yeah ladies and gentlemen um i would
like to warn you
you have young children we're gonna i'm
gonna ask everybody
to just try and use as much um
self-censorship and innuendo
to convey accurately what these ideas
are
and uh this is because it is adult
content we will not be uh getting into
explicitly
but it's a major news story
from fox news
post mates slammed over bottom friendly
pride month menu the postmates bottom
friendly menu drew a great deal of
criticism on social media from users who
criticized the company's pride month
move
let me just simplify this for you
post mates
made a commercial
for what's called a bottom menu
how do i describe this with um now
without crossing into pg-13 or r-rated
territory we can't even be pg-13 because
this is a definitely a pg this is an
x-rated story yeah
what this means is that postmates made a
video that was explaining how to engage
in adult gay activities
and was providing the service for it and
then went on to explain
why they were proud to do it
and they were you know
they said that they're tired of sex ed
being heterosexual or whatever and um my
attitude was just like i don't see
commercials from like dole or del monte
about pineapples and like couples and
why that's beneficial or anything like
that i don't you know we don't have
these commercials
so this commercial was like a bit over
the top but this is the intent
so i don't think the story here
necessarily is the pride month thing the
story i see here is
we have gotten to the point where the
attempts to shock the public to get
attention have become so drastic and
desperate
they're actually just collapsing
decaying and falling apart
it used to be shocking content was
saying a naughty word or something oh i
can't believe they would say that now
it's
or remember when it was shocking to see
a man's butt on tv it was like nypd blue
candle right it was what was it dennis
franz yeah detectives
yeah oh that was a great scandal in the
late 90s
on abc tv or something yeah i remember
because it also wasn't jimmy smith's it
was like really yeah come on he's the
cute one yeah come on man you couldn't
swear on tv yeah that's right now it's
just it's all kinds of crazy stuff so
what i see is this this ad
it was
i mean this is like x-rated stuff
they're talking about it's kind of crazy
i was shocked when you showed me this i
hadn't uh i hadn't been online much
today
that was enough i took a look at this
and i was just like oh my goodness
they're basically they're basically
explaining what i'm saying can you pull
up the ad yeah let's no i can't you
can't one of the fruits
of course i can't show it it's it's got
it
it shows like fruit peaches walking
around a peach plant fetish but there's
like right there's like kink stuff in
there yeah yeah yeah gross so weird they
did have one recently too where it was
like um
two buns that were both the top oh yeah
that's that's that's burger king yeah
that was the that was the tame version
of this burger they're topping burger
king in fact yeah so to me this is more
of the contagion of social media you
have to shock you have to make everyone
engage with what you're saying and it
doesn't matter if it's in the form of a
ratio and the quote to eats or if it's
people being positive about it in fact
negative attention is often more
engaging for people than positive
attention because it's just kind of how
we're wired yeah people are more likely
to comment yeah if they have something
negative to say rather than something
positive
it's a commercial explaining the
negative ramifications of a bad diet
while two dudes do it
here's what you need to eat and here's
why you need to eat it and i'm like wow
i never thought i'd see that i mean
what's cool if they were promoting
fasting well as a gay man here can i
yeah yeah what are my thoughts
i find this
offensive not because of
traditional or religious values but the
fact that
once upon a time much of the effort that
helped really to mainstream and
normalize
tolerance for
uh gay and lesbian people was the fact
of showing that we are just like you
and
now
these advertisement campaigns in recent
years and political campaigns and social
campaigns during pride are about
focusing on
like sex and explicitly sex and that's
i mean that was what originally made a
lot of people uncomfortable around uh
gay or lesbian people they always
thought about the sex and so fetish and
all that and then the fact you know that
this particular
advertising campaign is
focusing on
um anal sex and using references to
fetish gear to talk about what's that
had to do with delivering pride yeah no
food delivery exactly
so someone responded to their tweet
and they said if you are not literally
helping us have sex are you really an
ally and postmates said exactly and
that's blah blah blah and they're like
that's what we want to do and
i'm like i didn't realize my food
delivery service was required to help me
have sex well the other thing too is in
a lot of ways pride has morphed into
something of of just being pro proud of
your sex kinks right cometh before the
fall we've seen that like so the
washington post ran a whole piece about
why it's really important to take your
kids to pride so that they can see kink
fatherly recently ran a piece
talking about how it's really important
to take your kids to pride and to
explain to them what kink is there's all
of these pushes from um like you know
people advocating for more sex ed saying
that you have to talk about kink as part
of sex ed
but they're not talking about healthy
relationships they're not talking about
love they're not talking about you know
goals for successful partnership or any
of that it's just all about like this is
how you get off and getting off is the
main point of life they'll explain it as
a is love to encounter because it's
erotic love eros is a type of
bailey um i think that a sect of
humanity in the last 15 years has become
extremely or decentralized or not
decentralized desensitized to sex like
big time the kids that saw porn when
they were 9 10 years ago are 19 now and
they're kind of leading the charge
they're probably ceo postmates and then
there's a grand 19 year old maybe not
but soon and there's a grand percentage
of us that or people that are not
desensitized to it and are like freaked
out and are freaking out and those
people that are desensitized are having
fun with it they see that it's getting
reaction that other people can't take it
the puritans oh my god and so they're
just pushing it and because like you
can't stop me well i'm a united states
citizen and they're pushing it on kids
in order to justify their adult fetishes
i think that we should use law
enforcement for that kind of thing well
some people are trying because like if
you did that in a parking lot
you had um in texas they were working on
trying to it's
similar but different trying to
criminalize the
medical gender transition of minors it's
weird because like if there's a
community that wants to do weird sex
stuff you kind of just let them do their
weird sex stuff but then this is the
live and let live thing this is kind of
you know to a certain extent i wonder
i'm just throwing this out there
is it possible that this is how we got
here
for me it is i've had hands off for 20
years i've been like do whatever you
want do whatever i've always said that
too like whatever anybody wants to do
that's up to them uh but perhaps yes
perhaps yes do whatever you want to do
that's up to you but maybe it makes
sense to discuss the perils of hedonism
you know maybe it makes sense to discuss
the the difficulties that can arise from
using your body as a sex toy we have no
choice at this point and the
psychological effects of watching online
this is all very real and it contributes
to the meaninglessness of our society
and it contributes to the nihilism that
is so much more easily grasped than
you know
any of any of the stuff that actually is
fulfilling but not only that but to the
destruction of future relationships
because if people are desensitized and
they're on the internet and their
parents just give them a computer or a
phone and then they're able to be in
their own room by themselves they you
know go on websites that rewire their
brains to prevent them from having
healthy relationships as adults
so this is
you know in my opinion a larger plot of
the depopulation agenda this is one way
to prevent people from having children
from having healthy relationships
because if we really did care about you
know this stuff we would be talking
about healthy relationships
boundaries way to communicate your wants
and needs ways to have a healthy
relationship ways to coexist with
another human being by being able to
respect them as another human being and
not see them as an object so that would
be something that of course we could
have a conversation on but we don't all
we have is kink all we have is fetish
all we have is this weird stuff that you
could do because it's cool and trendy
and this corporation's telling you to do
this it's ridiculous it's it's so stupid
i think you're right that a lot of
people do this is a good opportunity an
uh example of us humanizing people that
we may not agree with and kids watch
this show which is a good thing
i have a working theory that they are
choosing the worst parts about these
lifestyles to make for example gay men
look terrible i think they're actively
taking steps it does make us look
terrible it does it looks terrible and
nobody wants to talk about the dark
parallel that runs with this super
encouragement of sexual promiscuity is
the dispos disproportionate rates of hiv
and sti infections in monkeybox
yeah i mean that's the story right now
yeah yeah
well i think if you're going to talk
about the health effects that you need
to consider when you're living a high
risk lifestyle you should talk about all
of them you should talk about the
problems that come with promiscuity you
should talk about so i should talk about
the problems that come along with
being in really intensely dysfunctional
relationships but they're not they're
just trying to make a splash and
it's so shallow and short-lived and i
think it's seriously throwing our
culture off balance so i mean we've also
like so clearly destroyed families yeah
you know i've been giving this a lot of
thought um
just personally about like my own life
and my family history and everything uh
my grandparents on both sides on my
mom's and dad's sides were both divorced
in the 70s
my parents got divorced um
i think they got divorced shortly after
both their parents got divorced you know
they got divorced um
my
my dad got divorced twice after that my
mom got divorced again after that you
know
my husband and i split up like what is
this like we can't this is
generations at this point of people who
cannot maintain a family structure
um you know and everybody you ask them
everybody's got a really good reason you
know everyone's got great reasons why
they couldn't maintain their their
marriages why they couldn't maintain
their families um but literally every
single one
is messed up and then i look at what's
uh let's pull this story around and i
look at my son and i'm like is how is he
gonna be able to maintain a marriage
like how you know
i want to pull up the story from the
post-millennial libby do you want to
read this one sure wait let me get my
glasses i can't see the long way over
there sorry no can you read it yes fox
news airs segment celebrating
transgender teen hannah nightingale
wrote this up today i was shocked when
she brought me this story um
and
said that she was going to write it up
fox news it turns out is as woke as post
mates perhaps they ran a puff piece on a
trans teen out of southern california
and they made claims and the mother
makes claims that it was painful for her
daughter to have to wear feminine
clothing
so that must mean that her daughter is a
boy as though wearing boys clothes makes
you a boy somehow it's like it's a
magical when i put on jeans and t-shirts
i'm a boy i'm a boy
america look at this look at this fox
news ran yes look at america together
celebrating diversity
lgbtq plus pride month please i have
really strong words that i would like to
say to fox news but this is my seven
million
family youtube video briana says the
story about that family that hopes their
experience can help others watch here
if you saw me walking down the street
you wouldn't
think anything different
fourteen-year-old ryland whittington is
a typical southern california teenager
and the whittingtons along with mom
hillary dad jeff and sister whatever
look yeah
my my it is uh whatever i think where's
the news where's the right i know like i
have two questions like i don't
understand why news is airing this story
i don't either i look because they're
owned by blackrock the ques the issues i
have are around
lack of parental rights
so in the schools if the if the children
are being exposed and keeping a seat
from their parents if the parents are
making decisions for their their kids
well there's questions about you know
where the parents rights are
and the the issue of
surgery
on children i don't know the full depth
of the story i think for me what i can
comment on is why is fox news airing
this
it's a really good question as to why
fox news is airing this and i think
somebody should ask fox news why the
why they are airing this
why they would be conceivably airing a
puff piece on a trans teen um who if
this teen goes through with all of the
the transness will end up leading a life
where they can never have an orgasm i
mean they're saying it's uh quote for me
it's the deep spiritual belief that if
you believe in god and he you know
created us the way he wanted us well
then yes he created ryland just the way
he is said the mother right which which
means that he that that rylan needs
nothing to be who rylan truly is doesn't
need any drugs doesn't need any surgery
doesn't need any changes cut your hair
wear whatever clothes you want in fact
without anything that's when you are who
you are that's who you truly are
exactly uh so uh this is a news corp
which owns fox and they have about seven
percent of the company is owned by the
the triad block rack block
vanguard state there's another one
called independent franchise partners i
think what they're doing is this is a
mutton bailey they give you the the um
the uh staged opposition you know the
the controlled opposition for a while
they did that for last couple years now
you're starting to see the real
propaganda controlled opposition is the
word here that i think is key to to
really understand a lot of the motives
of some of the republicans and some of
the republican news networks i mean
again what's the purpose here what's the
relevance how is this impacting my life
what does this have to do with me living
my life every single day it has nothing
to do with it and why am i
being told about this like it's crazy
what use has turned out to be well and
it's not just why are you being told
about this it's why is fox encouraging
parents to gender transition their
children yeah because that is what's
going on here this is no different than
when president biden got there got up
there on trans visibility day or
whatever that whatever it was called
um sorry i'm having trouble
yeah i'm trying why would you why would
anyone i'll say this i mean yeah you
know but why didn't i say that spiden
told parents to gender transition their
children right outside of this story
which um
you know i'm just gonna say you know as
an aside man i think it's a good
opportunity for people who are members
of fox nation to sign up for timcast.com
that is such a great idea
i totally stand private corporations
these public corps are dangerous these
people whoever ran this has absolutely
no ethics hey you know they're no
different than cnn you know who's not
owned by blackrock vanguard
all these people it's tim castle
well i will say that the post-millennial
and our sister publication human events
we are also not owned there's also
another group called we are change out
there
are you also independent
that was a big part of what elon was
doing well
as he wants to make it make it private
and i think that he's right we went to
you know vanguard straight state street
in blackrock and they didn't they
rejected us and then i was just like
well we don't want your money anyway
we're independent and you suck
they they do suck no i'm just crap
[Laughter]
i was outside waving my fist at them i
know what you're up to how many people
do you think are involved with owning
those corporations
well they they have commercials
and they tell people to put their
investment their their retirements yeah
we saw them last night yeah yeah they're
like invest with us i should start using
a different word than a corp mega corpse
mega corpse but even that is a word
corporation you know what about like
uh aberration eldritch horror yeah yeah
these horrors
what do you think about 20 guys am i
this is conspiracy theory time luke what
do you think
20 people own these companies do you
think it's more than like way more than
that some people say 13 but uh
who really knows
yeah that's a that's a hand like the
heads of families yeah
well the num i mean maybe if we got that
client list we might know you know what
i'm saying
yeah
the thread pulls deep on this one
remember the panama papers boy did that
get swept and that's that's that's
hidden so quickly there's like a woman
and she got murdered right
wait she got murdered how did i miss
that part i guess because it got covered
up by fox
when i go to sleep at night my my
nightmares are that it's already on
lockdown the whole world is already on
corporate lockdown by these companies
and that we're just along for the ride
you just were two years ago yeah two
years ago we're on corporate lockdown
but lockdown like spy network satellites
watching they're ready to kill anyone at
any time lockdown like just fall in line
or die kind of thing it's terri
i hope it's not like that but man i i
know that they have satellites i don't
know
elon musk satellites that he's using
right now in uh ukraine so what you got
a trick you got to trick the world into
changing
yeah i make them laugh their way to the
bank you have to you have to give people
and you have to like
tell people
how to find meaning and fulfillment in
their lives and not even how to but to
go search for that to go search for you
know don't tell people what to believe
or how to believe it but tell them with
an expression of faith
to go find these things for themselves
to figure it out to ask yeah yeah i
think
to speak
i think one of the ways the right wing
has really really failed has not been
giving a positive goal for people
because as we were saying before it's
constant reaction it is yeah and the
constant reaction is no way to move
forward you're not moving forward right
you're just saying this is bad this is
bad when you're standing at war history
yelling stop and it does need to be it
does need to be positivity you need to
you need to like give some way to find a
path i i think of this woman that i
talked to at tpusa or who asked this
question constantly because i'm thinking
like uh because one of her questions was
if you
um if you have no framework for meaning
or for a soul or for faith
how do you find it where do you begin if
you have absolutely don't have the
language we've taken the language away
from kids about meaning about faith
about a soul about you know any of this
stuff and we've replaced it with gender
garbage you know so fully
where do you begin if you are devoid of
all meaning if you are you know
miserable and you think that it's all in
your brain you don't even have the words
to go find
what it is that will that will help you
yeah it's the scientific method has been
there's too much weight and importance
put on that i think in our society
because it only can indicate what's it
just looks for patterns and if it can't
find a pattern it tells you it's not
real but the thing about god if there is
such a thing is it's not the same if
it's a pattern it's happening from
really far away and it looks like chaos
to us but there's still
something to it
i suspect that the right will win in the
end because they are actually asking
these questions and the left never will
we are at least attempting to be
somewhat self-aware
the right's going to win because they
have kids yeah it's true too that's it
that's true too but when you teach your
kids that you want to search for a
purpose and meaning and that that
purpose and meaning is not found within
yourself and that's incredibly
solipsistic to think that it is
then you're gonna have more success in
life overall and you're gonna be happier
like having kids is great but if they're
miserable and they're ready to be trans
what's the point it's like not having
kids at all you have to you have to
share
faith and love of life with them right
and you have to be in that position and
you know word too yeah and what's
interesting too is the way that we treat
children now is we treat them like you
know just another pleasure object right
if you look at
this whole thing um there's a doctor in
india who is certified by some board in
the u.s who is planning to transplant a
uterus into a
man good luck so that that man can feel
further feminine and this is after like
drastic reconstruction and like all of
the rest of it um
there is absolutely no thought given to
now first of all it's going to fail but
there's secondarily there's no thought
given to what will happen to this child
this child will be the product of an egg
from one person
the uterus for you know an egg from one
woman a uterus from another woman be
gestated in the body of a male who is
actually only doing this for their own
personal fulfillment to feel more female
uh
who who is this child who's this child's
mother who is the father my question is
like how do they attach the uterus well
it's going to not work it already
it already didn't work in mice like it
actually is is it is as stupid
as it sounds but even when you think
about like surrogacy or other things
where you have a child that is conceived
and gestated from like you know half a
dozen people or whatever
where are you from
what's your background what's your
culture
what's you know who's your mother
who's your daddy yeah
who's your daddy yeah that's the big
question these days right it is yeah uh
your environment i suppose genetics you
know obviously you're past the show the
tree comes into it but who's raising you
who's who's raising you and where are
you from i mean at a certain point you
know like when you talk to people who
have been adopted and they everyone
wants to know who their original parents
were at some point and when i feel like
maybe we're probably the issue here is
that we're placing far too much emphasis
on the physical body this is why we're
doing insane things like transplanting a
female uterus into the pelvis of a male
never going to work you should maybe
think about your soul instead i want to
make sure we get to this think about
your soul instead i want to make sure we
get to this story because i know this is
something that andy really wants to talk
about from the post-millennial secret
grand jury in san diego indicts alleged
antifa members accused of brutal
assaults
andy what's this about
so we just had the annie anniversary of
the day and every time that comes
uh
every year on social media you can
expect stupid hot takes from people
sharing photos of world war ii heroes
and saying that these this was the
original antifa
and uh along that they will what they're
trying to hint in is that suggests is
that
uh when we talk about violent when i
talk about violence extremist antifa
groups and networks today that it's a
figment of my imagination and those who
have been victimized by those militants
uh have made it up uh well in san diego
um a grand jury
um
met over 13 days last month was
presented with evidence by the
prosecutors
um that alleged antifa members from two
cells in los angeles and san diego
conspired to
and protest participated in a brutal
attack on uh the public
in the beginning of january last year
there was a trump rally and antifa
organized as they have always done where
they post the flyers online and where to
go
all the signs of organization and they
went there and they were really
indiscriminate in their violence they
attacked people that had nothing to do
with a rally a dog was injured um
if you looked at the indictment court
documents they brought weapons there
there's some video that was embedded
here
and um
my report that i occurred with even art
uh
and this is an exclusive for the
post-millennials that we were able to
get most of the photographs of the
suspects um san diego doesn't release
images of those who have been arrested
and so um this is literally an unmasking
of the suspects and if you look at the
charging documents
um the indictment it says explicitly the
allegations that these are anti-fun
members so
you know i
this won't happen but i wish this this
story or those court documents ended up
on the desk of every lawmaker in
congress especially those who have gone
on record over and over to deny the
existence of antifa
and um
this is a really big case in that so
there are 29 felony counts against the
11 suspects accused of being part of
those cells
uh included in that is felony conspiracy
and this is the first time anywhere in
the united states that those who are
accused of being part of the antifa have
been charged with conspiracy that's
significant
this should well we saw we saw uh
january 20th 2017 they charged all those
antifa conspiracy but
they actually got uh the charges
dismissed file the lawsuit then one
millions of dollars from dc
not surprised what's interesting is if
i'm
against fascism you would consider me
anti-fascism it doesn't make me part of
antifa because they could call their
organization happy guys and if they went
around and beat people up
you don't even have to be happy to be in
the happy guys it's just a group name
they call it antifa which doesn't mean
anything about has anything to do with
fascism they're angry and they're
beating people on the street apparently
we're going to call our organization the
good guys
yeah is going to be like we're literally
the good guys are you talking about it
we're called the good guys what is the
ethos of anti-fives and organization i
guess it's a lot of different disparate
factions that are all kind of under an
umbrella concept is that what you've
been able to like but what is do they
want peace are they trying to re
renegotiate society in a way yes so
broadly organizing under this concept of
being against fascism they believe in
violent direct action as being one of
the very effective tactics in achieving
their goals up and including up to and
including
terroristic acts
and so
the fact that democrats have
many have openly allied with this
um
antifa branding and messaging
it's
i mean that's really disturbing to me
because antifa is
as anti-liberal as it can be these are
people who believe that the response to
speech and ideas and expressions that
you disagree with is to
attack maim and or kill those people who
are expressing those views that is what
they actually believe which is why when
they organize their counter-direct
actions it's to bring like in this case
uh pepper spray bats
um other projectiles to throw up
people's heads and beat them with bats
and
you know this violence is caught on the
on cameras quite often and this evidence
is still denied over and over i hope
that people
read the story uh you can also go to the
san diego county prosecutor's office and
look at the charging documents
um
and
i mean
part of the reason why these antifa
groups themselves have felt so empowered
to carry out acts of violence over and
over is for the most part they've been
able to do with impunity literally i
want to point out when it comes to
activism there are two types according
to the way humans look at earth there's
direct action and then there's action
appealing to others which is like hey
you know fix our streets fix our streets
and there's direct action which is
fixing the street yeah go out either
economically or physically changing it
on your own
does this look like uh
tides are turning
like maybe that we're gonna start seeing
some action taken against antifa is it's
cause san diego no it's because the
prosecutor who is elected there is
somebody who's willing to enforce the
law and actually her candidate i forget
what year it was recently where the
she went into office but during the
campaign the person who's running
against her was a benef for that
campaign i forget her name but
the left-wing
prosecutor candidate in san diego county
had benefited from
uh soros super pac or pac money so
unfortunately san diego voters had voted
for somebody who appears to
want to apply the law evenly i don't
think this is a tide turning at all if
you scroll down the story by the way uh
so the rest for these suspects actually
happened around december of last year
and in some of the court documents um
that were retrieved from the the
co-author even art scroll down a little
more just after that like these are some
of the weapons that were seized from the
suspects so
you know these are people who are backs
who bring
deadly weapons to their so-called direct
actions and have access to weapons that
can kill lots of people and they
explicitly they're allowed to but when
you have a deadly weapon and then you
commit an assault on someone that should
up the charges to assault with a deadly
weapon
well they're they're open about their
violent extremist views and their calls
for
killing people so i think
you know i i don't know if it's worth it
to get into second minute my view is
they got a first amendment so they can
say dumb things but you can't incite to
violence they got a second amendment so
they can walk around with guns while
doing it but they attacked people they
did they heard a dog allegedly allegedly
if you're gonna go around with a weapon
like that and actually attack people you
are committing assault
with a deadly weapon so that's a that's
a much much more serious charge and good
that's what that's what it's for it
seems like this violent direct action
that has been happening has been kind of
lost in the noise the last couple years
because there's so much news that it's
just like a lot of things it's hard to
sift through it but
it's real and i feel like our government
or national guard should be on high
alert against violent direct action
right now
well they are when it comes from the
right
yeah they're very focused on that or the
wrong right
who's right the right or the wrong or
the left i'm not sure what's going on
here uh any anyhow maybe so far they
have been and
that's fine but i just all around we
need to protect our streets and our and
our people well when they talk about
fighting domestic terrorism they're not
talking about these guys when merrick
garland comes out there and he says you
know domestic terrorism is this huge
threat they're not talking about these
antifa guys right they're talking about
like the people that showed up in
lansing and wanted their businesses to
be allowed to be
opened they're talking about you know
parents at school board meeting parents
yeah
yeah exactly that's crazy it's important
to point these violent direct actions
out by all people when it's happening
especially right now as the economy is
inflating even when that man was
threatening to try to take brett
kavanaugh out they were on the news
saying well these threats definitely
come from both sides we need to keep in
mind that it's you know from both sides
and we have to take into account you
know i don't know like parents at school
board meetings and stuff and i'm like
and it's just not accurate take the
plank out of your own eye people before
you try to take the speck out of the
right wing's eye honestly it's really
exhausting if trump was responsible for
the actions of some of his supporters i
wonder why those who have been inciting
violence day in and day out in response
to the abortion stuff haven't been held
responsible for the alleged actions of
this foiled murder-suicide plot well you
could apply it retroactively too with
the shooting at the baseball field where
steve scalise almost died that was a
bernie supporter nobody cared about that
they didn't try to attach bernie to him
we didn't either because we're like it's
not bernie doing this in the same way we
said it but the thing too 529 yeah
that's right yeah yeah the thing too
though is we saw even when trump was in
office we saw the democrat left
saying that um it was acceptable to
harass and target members of the trump
administration when they were in public
right telling wasn't like
sarah sanders was like basically
harassed at a waffle house she was
harassed out of a waffle house am i
remembering that i think tucker and his
family yeah and there were a lot this
happened a lot maxine waters said it get
in their face it's happened to me in d.c
it happened to you in d.c
it allegedly happened to you in new
orleans but it wasn't really you oh yeah
it was not me it happened to some random
asian stranger they keep doing that yeah
wow sam hyde level there was that video
of that dude he's like an asian guy and
they're like you're andy no and he's
like no i'm not i'm like yes you are and
he's like no i'm not and it's clearly
not you it's the crazy thing
it's like
i don't know i think it's because they
don't actually know who you are they've
heard your name yeah so then someone
sees an asian guy and they're like
that's andy no because asian must be him
and then the people who don't know him
so this happened to me when i was at um
i was at uh which university is up on
the upper west side of new york is it
columbia columbia
uh mike cernan was speaking there
several years ago so i yeah several
years ago i went there to just go film
and there's a protest and then someone
yelled out that's tim poole don't let
him film you
no one knew who i was so they all start
looking around confused and then i look
around with them like oh
who are we looking for right because i'm
not stupid i know
if i
like oh you just started looking around
too you're like i acted like they acted
because it made it impossible
so they pointed out some old guy with a
camera and a vest and then some some
dudes going you're the reason that we
and this old guy is going like like
shrugging but now everyone's looking at
him then the activist goes no no not him
him him and he's pointing at me and then
i'm just looking around like what's
going on like
and then eventually
they figured out he was talking about me
some young woman went to the police
there and started making things up about
me saying this guy's violent and he's
trying to he's telling his friends to
come and kill us right now and then i
walked up and i pulled out my my press
card
of which i have numerous because i
worked at vice i worked at abc and then
i was like sir i don't know these people
and then i showed them they were like
we're sorry about that man and then they
actually were just like ma'am you go
away and then she got really angry like
oh her lies didn't work
but they don't actually know
so when they see an asian guy and
someone says andy no they're like that's
him that's all that matters because
they're they're psychotic you know right
well i am peeling now as indirect
non-violent action to the fbi if you
guys want to stop street violence like j
edgar hoover did with the mob i mean
now's the time we got they are the mob
come on nip it in the bud because these
guys if they're really organizing and
beating people up on the streets we got
to stop it now
you're saying i know you're beating me
up but if you want to stop you from
beating me up no i'm talking about these
these guys dressed in black kicking dogs
right shooting i don't know if there are
people involved in it that work for the
national government or not but if you're
listening which you are listening right
now and you want to stop this now's the
time
the left even thinks they're feds
like they all accuse each other of being
cops
so when uh like i said people show up in
front of the home of a supreme court
justice openly breaking the law
and genseki says we encourage this
you're asking them
to arrest themselves it's like i'm their
people are building the sand humps dunes
and i'm saying do you let's just start
taking the sand and putting it in
another area it's we're not going to fix
it tonight but it's so they wanted to
happy stories why would they stop it
i they is very vague i'm not not
everyone in the federal government is
monolithic right
he says we encourage this that's biden's
doj why would merrick garland appointed
by biden go up against what they're
doing i'm not talking about garland i'm
talking to the people working at the fbi
you guys and who do you think who do
they take orders from to go out and do
these things
it's the doj it's it's it's biden's
appointees and gen zaki clearly said we
encourage you i understand that you
receive orders from your superior but if
it's a bad order you have an obligation
there's also enforcing orders they
haven't been given
the point is if whistleblowers are
coming out saying the fbi is purging
conservatives genseki says we encourage
their behavior merit garland won't take
action against them and was appointed by
biden don't expect to ask the
administration that is encouraging this
to happen to enforce anything against it
it's like saying a dude going out he's
like i'm going to go buy a pie you
should stop yourself from buying pie
he's going to be like bro i told you i
want this i'm not expecting anything out
of this
i'm just saying we got the we got the
machine in place to work on this stuff
so let's work on it
what do you mean we have an fbi they
they investigate domestic crimes that's
what we do do they i'm not i'm not yeah
cynicism is not going to get us out of
this let me let me try this again yeah
but they're already yeah i'm not doing
it
the fbi is joe biden's department of
justice
janseki said their administration is
encouraging the protests the fbi why
would the fbi the fbi doesn't report to
joe biden the fbi reports to itself
sure i i in a manner of speaking but if
whistleblowers are saying they've purged
conservatives merrick garland is the one
who's in charge
why are they going to enforce against
what they want talking to merrick
garland i mean merrick if you're
listening right
you're asking for like the last
americans that are listening right now
you said to the fbi yeah everybody
that's there everyone that has the
opportunity to do something about this
now now now we we start moving now and
we can fix our economy they're they're
too busy trying to coax mentally ill
people to do their work for them
um but uh yeah a lot of people
know ian i've said my piece my friends i
love you
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com become a
member to support our work you'll get
access to exclusive segments of this
show monday through thursday at 11 pm
there's a huge library of all of these
members only shows check them out and we
will read your super chats we got a
whole bunch
all right jeff pearson says the
government is the only entity that can
create inflation it is not a natural
product of the market it is purely a
printing press issue
that's not true banks can create
inflation if they're
cheating
but you know like when the government
engages in a ponzi scheme we just go
sure
yeah
right
all right let's see we got grofty says
buck buck buck oh yeah thank you thank
you uh rip chuan egg yeah did you guys
hear oh yeah that was so sad i heard
no known next of can no well i was wrong
about that uh on egg
our chicken old chicken yeah yeah
chicken a chicken i'm sorry named shuan
egg yeah
i miss her
so i was told by our chicken tender kim
that the two adopted ones are really old
and probably not going to make much
longer she did have a next of kin oh a
sister is a next of kin okay yeah so i
didn't realize you know but no children
and so i'm wondering though i don't
think they were laying eggs okay so and
if that's the case there's no yeah they
stopped laying so shoe on egg was the
the end of the line really yeah okay sad
i wonder if we incubated any of their
babies though maybe
i don't know they were laying eggs
over a year ago and they stopped and
they've been just not doing well there
was actually a third chicken that didn't
make it because they were just not doing
well mm-hmm
lived a good life died of old age
yeah yeah yeah it's a good life in
chicken city did it become a meal
no
no no
no i think we would have had to have
moved faster
oh that makes converting it into food
yeah i think you have to kill it
yourself really to make it be yes be
fresh yeah and make it be food but we
have we have some gags in mind for the
vlog we'll see what happens
an orange sea lion says has coffee brand
coffee left you hyper well andy no will
surely lead to another swatting that
will leave you speechless by michael
knowles now available in paperback that
was good
that was that was a good double super
chat and he knows unmasking will lead to
speechless yeah
david box says i drive a 99 suburban and
it costs nearly 200 to fill it up it has
a 42 gallon tank biden has to go or
america is screwed come on man just just
get a tesla that's right it's only fifty
four thousand dollars come on you know
how hard is that really you just work
for a couple days and then
i think i think these like you just send
your son to ukraine to make you a lot of
money exactly buy yourself a tesla look
you get your kid in ukraine for one
month and you can buy yourself a couple
right yeah a couple teslas that's that
easy huh make sure you're sharing bank
accounts though otherwise it's illegal
because he's transferring money to you
right but so is sharing okay nevermind
never mind
okay what do we get
adrian contreras says you're talking
about the fed and natural gas with ian
and luke sitting there why do you hate
us tim
natural gas that's methane that's right
amongst other things i think
pedro henrique says tim did you see
bolsonaro calling out mark ruffles on
twitter the hollywood establishment is
going nuts with the idea of him being
re-elected
well there you go oh hey what's this ry
lyon says phoenix ammunition has been
suspended from twitter yeah free phoenix
that's right i don't know why he said he
was eating dinner with his family then
he came back and he suspended
permanently so i have no clue what he
permanently the permanent that's a big
one yeah it might have been the way the
name of his account he changed his name
to like blow the lung out phoenix
ammunition below making fun of that
biden statement about getting a long
loan out yeah and it looked like it was
like telling people to do it
grand chi says 64 percent of u.s
electric electricity currently comes
from natural gas most common way we get
natural gas it's a by-product of
drilling for oil
you can also get it from the bottom of
trash heaps produces natural methane
yeah they they cover the dumps
and then capture all the methane gas and
that's staten island
that's right
there you go
all right on adrian contreras says what
happens if 150 million people are trying
to charge a freaking car at once
we can't even sustain running our air
conditioning in ca without blowing out
the power grid that's right
there's going to be a huge shortfall
apparently this summer of electricity
rolling out of electricity in california
i'm really excited because we got our
solar completed now nicely done yup
tesla uh failed us
oh you were going to do tesla solar so
we did tesla we have we have a couple
different facilities our new facility
that we're building we've got solar
getting set up we tried tesla they
vanished for a year and we just went no
idea what's going on they finally showed
up and delivered all the equipment and
we're like all right and then they went
hey wait a minute this won't fit your
building and then we're like what and
they're like also we gotta shut off all
your power to your studio for several
hours
and then hope the electric company turns
it back on and i was like
you didn't tell us that was gonna happen
this other company showed up right away
installed everything and said we gotta
wait for permitting permitting took a
bit to be fair and they came and
finished all the work and i didn't even
see them free market nicely done yeah
smaller companies mm-hmm and i like
tesla you know elon what up it looks
like he's working on uh elon and tesla
working on a new manganese battery cell
oh interesting i've also heard them
talking about graphene batteries
graphene batteries
pearson says world inflation increases
because of the central banks and
printing of the us dollar government
creates inflation
yep inflation is stuffed well it's not
the printing of money it's the um
what are we on now are we on an infinite
reserve
they removed the reserve
fractional reserves banking is how the
money supply is expanded upon the
issuance of debt money is created in the
system so you buy a house they just
create the money put in your bank
account
so no one's actually lending it but they
have to have a certain amount of money
available in reserve someone told me
that because of the pandemic they
removed the reserve cap now it's
infinite they can just yeah it is that's
why the money supply is skyrocketing if
you look at the m1 it's so difficult to
tell and i would doubt that they would
ever come out on the news and be like
now banks can print as much money as
they want out of nothing like they're
not going to tell anyone
they're just going to do it print i
think is like the wrong word because it
implies there's some kind of process by
which the money is entering circulation
like like a machine makes it and then
they like test it they're literally just
in the bank going like one million
dollars enter so and then it's like boop
there it is so weird how does that
really yeah yep yeah isn't that weird
that's not a that's not a good situation
every time you spend the money on your
credit card fantasy money every time you
spend money on a credit card you're
creating money unicorn money that's
fantasy money that is fantasy money
don't like that take it away which
indicates either of you
yeah i told you so
it kind of makes it sound like if it's
if it's invisible fake money then if we
get rid of it it won't be that bad
that's what it sounds like
right but if that's the only money in
your account and they just start
decreasing your zeros like then you're
screwed one of my favorite
bits ever was by the the rapid news guys
and they did a ron paul wrap
and then ron paul at the end is like
wearing all these gold chains and he's
like i'm ron paul and i approve this
message and then paul gets big and then
a square appears around the a you and
paul and it turns into the old
absolutely genius hey you and paul for
gold isn't that weird that ron paul is
like the aus right there he just worked
out so perfectly coincidence
all right
reyna says dr pamela susan fairchild at
the university of michigan is performing
transition surgeries on young children
do that information as you will wow
wait who was it tell me that pamela
susan fairchild i'm gonna write that
down yeah is that a prominent person or
something
i don't know i'm gonna find out though
let's find out
helmsway says i ate some of the keto
cake sour patch lids made today life is
better for the moment oh i'm happy to
hear that we had fun making keto angel
food cake i also made keto hummingbird
cake i don't think that one was like as
good but people seem to enjoy it so
thanks brian
salt of the street says love everything
y'all do we here at salt of the streets
podcasts are trying to do our part two
tomorrow at noon we'll be live on
youtube talking about many of the same
issues covered tonight hope to see you
there very nice thank you for the super
chat yeah
all right where are we at
rodolfo ramirez has left us see the
individual conservatives see the
statistics
hmm
yeah well maybe
no saint says jeremy did get swatted
again but coffee brand coffee has an
amazing
had amazing sales the last two days
weird ricketta also was talking about
getting swatted as well yeah they both
got spotted
yeah wow man
it's going around
catching h music says ruth sent us
posted the school and daily schedule of
amy coney barrett after the would-be
assassin at kavanaugh's house saying
this is the time now that a wake-up call
has been sent i mean they're they're
like
they're literally calling for war
yeah they said call to arms i said
here's the address it is stochastic
terror outright and they say that that's
what we're doing right they everything
they say we're doing is what they are
doing meanwhile mitch mcconnell is like
slow down they're above a crowd because
he's a turtle i i i do think mcconnell
should get some credit for not letting
garland on the supreme court yeah that's
true
that's like the one really good thing he
did thank goodness
harley chuck says tim go watch wendover
productions video on rising gas prices
very enlightening also you want people
from the left who can back up their
positions go watch some more news and
timba
stronger than stone says do you think
government and state officials in red
states and counties are in talks about
the possibility of civil war secession
and the supply shortages i believe they
are yes
because we've had for four years
mainstream media from like the guardian
the atlantic new york mag talking about
a civil war coming there's no way that
government officials have not been being
have not been briefed on that and you've
got to keep in mind a lot of those
companies you're naming off are owned by
blackrock so the com blackrock would
love to see a united states civil war
block rap blackrock they would a
multinational corporate conglomerate
megacorp they want us to go to war with
ourselves so that it'll fall
this union is the strongest defense
mechanism we have against corporate
oligarchy
white paper casters i hope you find the
punks that keep swatting you
yeah me too yeah yeah i know it's like
it's like the government's incompetent
here and can't do their job crazy kane
iv says fallout says war never changes
metal gear says war has changed might be
the guns of the patriots instead of
proxy wars with current day media
fall it's a great game by the way
oh white paper with another big super
chat thank you very much appreciate it
thank you
brian says republicans are the minority
they can't hold hearings there's nothing
stopping anyone from the smallest state
level to the highest federal level of
holding their own hearing
their i mean they can have people come
in and and testify and do whatever they
want
like nothing's coming from the january 6
hearings it's not like they're bringing
people in and actually having them do
anything meaningful i heard their
ratings were not good
bobcat oh really do we have the ratings
numbers no i don't have the numbers in
front of me bobcat says why aren't
conservatives suing to disqualify
democrats who supported the blm rides in
2020. blm declared revolution against
the u.s their supporters cannot hold
office because the democrats and the
republicans are the uniparty
donald trump got in bernie sanders
didn't it's all that matters and the
republicans are doing everything in
their power to oust donald trump you
know what though i think things will
change very very much so when the
boomers age out because they just won't
let go
the boomers in politics they are the
uniparty it's going to be very different
yeah it seems like there's an economic
calamity and they don't know what to do
about it they're just not there mentally
capacity capacity-wise so they're
turning on each other to attempt to seem
relevant and those political persecution
crap but we have bigger fish to fry
so just news says that um
comparable uh political events draw drew
in far more people than the january 6th
hearings which is in no numbers there
are numbers almost 20 million viewers
tuned in for the hearing on thursday
night according to the hill by contrast
president biden state of the union
address in march pulled in 38 million
viewers in 2018
then president donald trump's first day
of the union attracted over 45 million
per the new york post i mean 20 million
still a lot of people not nothing yeah
yeah but still
yep definitely not what they were hoping
for
well they got every major network to
just give them right an open mic night
except fox right yep
so are they counting fox in those
numbers no i don't think so because fox
was probably like 3 million
not sure tucker probably got 3 to five
million
postal pacif pacifist says january 6 was
not an isolated incident look up january
6 2017 protesters broke into the capital
albeit on a smaller scale to protest the
votes being counted and then candidate
trump really that happened january 6
2017 let me look that up
forest vikings says tim had billboard of
the carnage of 529 and a link or qr
leading everyone to a page explaining
what happened most billboards do not
allow politics
or anything related to politics we
actually had one billboard say because
our ad says politics in it they were
like we don't want that really yeah
they're like we have a book coming out
we have music like those are fun they're
like but
politics is it opens the door it has a
lot to do with laws around politics so
there's concerns that they're like we do
not want to get involved in that fec
stuff
because you know
then they got they got to fill up
paperwork and stuff like that
others are just like don't care give me
money
the bronx says it costs just as much or
more to charge your tesla as it does to
fill up a tank of gas check the price of
electricity
we
have solar
well not here we will
at the new facility be able to charge
off of the sky
yeah that'd be great so is your solar
connected to the grid because solar gets
connected to the grid and then you
basically get a discount on the energy
that you're buying from the grid yeah
they do but but only if you're actually
so only if if you use their energy
so usually what happens is you get
credits if during the day you're kicking
back into the grid then at night
you'll get credit you'll still draw it
down you never really make money you get
a discount right you know so
for the most part it's kind of like oh
yeah whatever right yeah but it's like
you're supplying extra energy for the
grid as well yeah now another thing is
most solar uh has batteries in your
house so we maxed out we're like give us
the most you possibly can
so during the day you charge up the
batteries to fall and then at night they
deplete so we're we'll basically be off
the grid
yeah that's cool big problem with grids
is if like you're a giant city huge city
grid if one area goes down they shut
down the entire grid that's why i was
asking about it yeah because you don't
want your stuff to get set down right
you need your house to be able to detach
that's huge keep it wrong when the rest
goes down
all right austin deworsk says been a
longtime supporter if i wanted to
sponsor the show to promote my podcast
formula fellas on all major platforms
where would i go could be useful for
other fans of the show who want to offer
more support and help with expanding
your up
so we have there's actually depending on
where you listen if you listen on
youtube there's a different company
the the on youtube
is where uh if you go to like the about
section i think that's where we have the
email contact for the sales
i don't know the email for the podcast
sales i think they do direct sales
completely on their own yeah i don't
know if they do solicitation but you can
email spin the ufo i suppose you can
yeah
hunter counts says tim says this like
the republican party aren't obviously
controlled opposition
they're not controlled opposition
they are the unit party they are the
establishment yep that's it there you go
it's like i'm not gonna they are one
yeah i'm not gonna be like antifa is
secretly working with antifa i'm like
they are antivirus right that's who they
are
raymond g stanley junior says ian
deserves a hard 20 tonight
swat the like button
that's right swat that like thank you
raymond and definitely click that like
button indeed all right matt fantazi
says libby tim you guys should get eyes
on a story in utah local d.a is accused
of ritual abuse of children watch
interview on quite frankly yesterday
with zell brothers who have source
inside investigation story is crazy i'm
going to write it down
utah local d.a systematic abuse of
children quite frankly yesterday with
zell brothers
cold slimes as you mentioned the apple
pie law in massachusetts they still have
a law that a flag bearer must be present
100 feet in front of an automobile in
order not to scare the horses oh wow
that's a great law that's very cool and
so why aren't people getting arrested
yeah what the heck not enforced yup
still there please don't get to just
choose that's not fair
that would be hysterical though if they
just went out to every car like yo
you're literally all around times have
changed
they could if they wanted to right mlp
says citizens united versus federal
election commission justices rule five
to four supreme court rules corporations
are people wake up people that's right
corporations are people my friend
citizens united is nuts except they
don't go to jail when they commit crimes
and poison people and steal people's
property and then rob people of their
wealth and happiness steal all the water
yeah
that's nestle poisoned the food supply
well who wasn't that some was maybe one
of the libertarian guys calling for the
corporate death penalty
interesting which is that when when
corporations commit egregious acts they
lose theirs
no they just dissolved you know that
they would just uh corporate the
corporate entities that exist now would
just use esg as a as a reason to kill
companies and then they'd just go after
tesla oh they would they would use the
corporate death penalty for their own
rights yeah yep
i mean
if you don't want it used for esg
don't put that in place david c cronk
senior says for shamed him even the word
innuendo is bottom friendly
cronk
all right
peanut pirate says tim implementing
speed limits actually causes more wrecks
in the 90s montana didn't have a speed
limit on the highway and in 2000 they
set limits car crashes went up
considerably i remember the same thing
for stop signs yeah i was i read
somewhere that stop signs increased the
accidents because what happened was when
there were no stop signs everybody would
would cautiously approach the
intersection
but when they put up stop signs some
people think
i'm going to blow the stop sign but the
other person won't or you won't have a
stop sign and they will so you'll assume
they're going to stop and you just won't
even look like natural pelosi's husband
isn't that what he did yeah
well he was drunk yeah but also but
first he rammed his uh
portion to a jeep yeah blowing a stop
sign and then
yeah well then later he got picked up on
the dui yes and i think they let him off
well we should let him go i wonder why
we we cannot be a country
could you imagine what the streets would
be like if the nobles were being locked
up i'd i'd rabble i just don't know what
would happen
no they would say well
troops we need gentlemen to be free to
reign over the rebels
we need them to be able to ram their
porsches into jeeps that's right that's
really important well libby have you
asked maybe the jeep deserved it oh yeah
the jeep always deserves it that's fair
yeah i bet the jeep wasn't even damaged
[Laughter]
all right please uh unfold in all
seriousness don't drive drunk man please
don't yeah people people get like
insanely confident and that's the
problem but uh
i do not get insanely confident
but people yeah they think like no i'm
fine i can drive and it's like dude
you're drunk you don't you you're wrong
give me your car definitely you cannot
drive
clayton johnson says the big question
for ian is who owns state street
blackrock and vanguard that's what i
asked luke earlier you know thirty each
other people yeah they own each other
which is weird when you start looking
into it and then
i don't know the names you know and
that's probably
it's probably out there yeah i'm sure it
is
okay what do we get
scott
marahu says stop with all the democracy
talk the us is a constitutional republic
only representative from your district
vote you don't
you know it's funny because i feel like
people who don't watch the show
regularly will say that all the time
when we make that point way too often
like we talk about how we're not a
democracy all the time then someone
tunes in like for the first time or like
once in a while and they're like
yeah like when people we i think we've
made probably like a hundred grand and
people telling us to watch yuri besmanov
oh
i'm not exaggerating that number i'm
willing to bet like
a hundred thousand dollars in people
being like watch the yuri bes mission of
an interview and it's like oh another
one of you got like 12 percent dollar
for every time jesus no i think we get
five dollars every time that's great
it's perfect yeah it's even better than
the dollar yeah i need a fund for yuri
besmanov i think i'm supposed to watch
that you should do that
right
your pal jody says as the founding
father patrick henry once said give me
liberty or give me death those dudes we
will not obey do not tread on me vote in
local elections run for local office
yeah wasn't it like 45 people are
running in alaska
really some ridiculous numbers
everybody's like we are stepping up to
the plate good for them yup it's an
uphill battle cause chaos yeah it can be
won
and marjorie taylor green proves it
lauren bobert proves it thomas massey
proves it donald trump proves it rand
paul yeah
all of these overturning school boards
as well there's all these school boards
where conservatives are being elected
yeah yeah recall efforts in san
francisco yes oh yeah
was it is it boudin how do you pronounce
it
boudin i was calling him bowdoin
i was calling him cheese
cheese
cheesy bowden
we were talking about that yesterday on
andy's podcast is so fascinating that he
got taken out yeah you know who really
loved him was those white progressives
and everybody else they sure did
they sure loved
that daniel trunka says any chance next
time you guys get swatted you can make a
quick transition to the rv you used in
tennessee rather than drop the show keep
it the great work
um i don't think you can because how do
we transfer the show over we would we
would be like a remote camera setup like
a remote rig connecting already to this
one or something i bet anything it's
possible maybe we'll build something
similar like something like that for the
next uh studio i i don't think the new
location's gonna have any problems ever
never none no no yeah yeah probably not
none yeah west virginia is a different
story yeah yeah
west virginia that's right you tell me
about west virginia it is a different
story a very very different story
all right
adam cloud says reread the giver
recently and i'm pretty sure the pills
they gave the 12s were puberty blockers
children belong to society and you apply
to receive a child from the state jeez
interesting that's messed up
all right
youtube
jump classic youtube yep once we get to
the bottom all right what's this raymond
g stanley jr says ian you hear about
ford using graphene and new trucks yeah
i was just reading about that i think
there's actually a timcast.com article
about it from adrian norman um they're
working with rice university and they're
like
they're they're breaking back i think
what they're doing is they're using
lasers to break back down materials of
old failing trucks and then they're
putting the graphene that's created from
the laser which is called flashing the
carbon and they're putting it back into
the new materials to make them lighter
and more sound resistant wow
let's see um
cinero says they announced the
suspension of the 10 reserve requirement
on the fed website in
2020. wow tell me that again they
suspended the 10 reserve requirement it
was on the fed's website in 2020.
well there it is dude infinite reserve
lending if that's that if that if if i
mean
suspended until further just google it
real quick because that basically means
the country ended on that day yeah
people don't realize that's them pulling
the plug out of the middle of the ocean
and all of the water being flushed out
because if they can just give out
infinite money with no restraint
this is why you're seeing inflation
skyrocket rapidly and why it won't stop
and the economy is going to implode
completely yeah this is what led to the
2008 housing market crisis well they
started a reserve requirement this is
different
well yeah of course this is not easy to
find at first glance banks are no longer
required to hold reserves this is from
april 2020 from
libertarianinvestments.com
if that's true man that's really scary
press release from the federal reserve
dot gov
federal reserve actions to support the
flow of credit to households and
businesses this is march of 2020.
all right well we'll just get this one
more right here corgi says tim are you
guys hiring right now my friend at the
washington post just lost her job
she's wicked smart just don't make jokes
around her she's bipolar
[Music]
what was great was felicia sonmez in
going totally crazy for a couple of days
proved that the joke was kind of right
yeah she really did prove it
wow that's great well i don't think
she's gonna be getting a job anytime
soon not from us yeah i mean she
wouldn't stop they were asking like
please stop they even posted something
saying like as part of the policy you
know here's what's funny so for those
who don't know this washington post
reporter like lost it on twitter
was yelling at all like because some
dude made it like retweeted a joke it
was even kind of funny it was a great
job the joke
the joke he retweeted was every woman is
bi you just need to find out if it's
polar or sexual and you do that's true
and so she complained he got suspended
dave weigel
she kept going on complaining he
apologized she got suspended yeah she
kept going on and complaining about the
work environment and then the washington
post published we have new policies if
you do these things
like you cannot do these things and it
basically said attacking your colleagues
on on the social media on social media
and then she kept doing it and then they
fired her it was clear they created that
policy for her
and then she broke it and then she broke
it and they were like they wanted to
fire her they needed a way to fire her
cleanly so they made the policy she
broke it they fired her
who in their right mind would hire her
ever again
she's maybe she'll get a sub stack yeah
she'll get a stock or she'll go to like
jezebel or something right yeah probably
like that all right everyone if you
haven't already smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
that is the most powerful thing you can
do if every single person who watched
just posted it on social media we would
be the biggest show in the world
overnight that would be awesome we
really do appreciate your support you
can follow the show at tim cast irl on
instagram where we post clips
we got banned on tick tock whatever you
can follow me everywhere twitter and
instagram at timcast andy do you want to
show anything out yeah my twitter handle
is mr
andy ngo i have a link tree slash a n d
y ngos just my name thank you everyone
i'm libby emmons i'm at libby evans on
twitter and i'm up at the post
millennial every day sweet and uh if you
guys like the shirt that i'm wearing you
get your own on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com i think it's
important for people to speak up and
raise their voice wearing a shirt is one
very easy way to do that and it's your
smart you know your small way of doing
activism i got a lot of different shirts
all on the best political shirts.com and
because you're there i'm here thanks for
having me uh i want to tell you guys a
little story about the federal reserve
requirements because it looks like they
may have gotten rid of any reserve
requirement this is from
federalreserve.gov it says here reserve
requirements for many years reserve
requirements played a central role in
the implementation of monetary policy by
creating a stable demand for reserves in
january 2019 the fomc announced its
intention to implement monetary policy
in an ample reserves regime reserve
requirements do not play a significant
role in this
operating framework anyway it's
obfuscation but here it comes
in light of the shift to an ample
reserves regime the board has reduced
reserve requirement ratios to zero
percent
effective on march 26 this is 2020. the
beginning of the next reserve
maintenance period this action
eliminates reserve requirements for
thousands of depository institutions
that was the support lending tax that
was holding businesses that was that was
pre-coveted yeah that was right around
the time the covet stuff started
happening yeah
yeah they must have no idea it was gonna
happen yeah probably i'm not going into
conspiracy hey everyone i i do i don't
know you but if i did i'd probably tell
you i love you to your face so have a
good night i'm ian cross and i'll catch
you next week and i am sour patch liz on
twitterminds.com you can find all of my
socials all my writing and my cat at
sarahpatchlids.me
check out
chickencitylive.com if you want to watch
sleeping chickens right now do chicken
stuff we have too many chickens because
they had a ton of babies and then we we
grew the babies and now we got way too
many babies but it's fun to watch
and uh yeah uh hang on hang out over
there because there's a chat and it's
another live show with but you know it's
chickens and um it's great we'll see you
all next time thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you